in the shadow of an old British colonial
building is a new British effort
after Mass complaints of inaction UK
Consular support is now underway and
their base has shifted from the heart of
the conflict in the capital to Port
Sudan I mean at a first glance it
doesn't look great it's a bit chaotic
but it is a much better option than
what's out there these people have
traveled a long way and they get some
water supplies and an opportunity to
potentially leave on an evacuation
mission of foreign Nationals and people
who have documentation to go abroad
the foreign office has advised British
Nationals to come here if they need help
leaving Sudan as unscheduled chartered
ships arrive from Saudi Arabia to
evacuate foreigners
some have departed and others patiently
wait hoping to qualify if you have you
know
a foreign passport
or any I think that will actually give
you a chance to go outside
they will take it and this is why
everybody here is doing his best to go
out of Sudan and what about people who
don't have American passports your
family your friends oh yeah I feel sorry
for Debbie you know because the
situation is not good I you know I
usually if they could have this uh you
know documents so they can leave you
know because you know it's terrible
there people are drained from the shock
not only of violence but abrupt
separation who would you have brought
with you here if you could
my whole family technically sometimes I
just feel like when I'm leaving I feel
like a traitor to my country I'm leaving
them in all this pain while I'm going to
go and have joy I feel like sometimes
you feel like a traitor for doing that I
don't know why
across town more people wait
exposed to the Searing heat with little
support we want to go back out because
every person here is no have money no
you can say sleep out on the out areas
not in the hotels not in the all people
are sleeping on the roads
location you know the cleaning that's a
good
the quality of the waiting room varies
by passport just like the chances of
evacuation a lottery for a better life
that starts at Birth
Sky News Port Sudan